[Musique]
les tissus de bambou doux pour la peau
dur pour la nature le bambou une matière
renouvelable qui pousse rapidement qui
nécessite peu d'eau ou d'engrais et qui
possède en plus des propriétés
antibactériennes on voit d'ailleurs de
plus en plus de vêtements ou d'ensemble
de draps par exemple fabriquer à partir
de cette matière et plusieurs marques en
vente les mérites mais la viscose et la
rayonne de bambou sont-elles vraiment
des fibres naturelles et écologiques pas
exactement d'abord le procédé de
fabrication de ces fibres nécessite
beaucoup de produits chimiques qui
peuvent être nocifs pour l'environnement
et pour la santé des travailleurs dans
les usines de plus une fois transformé
en viscose ou en rayonne le bambou n'est
plus antibactérien donc si un fabricant
vente les mérites écologiques de ces
tissus pour vous inciter à acheter ces
produits c'est de les cours blanchiment
et ça c'est illégal au Canada alors si
vous tenez à la douceur du bambou pour
la peau délicate du petit dernier optez
plutôt pour le lit au sel ou le temps
seul dont la transformation nécessite
des produits moins dommageables passez
le mot
[Musique]